Hey Youtubers it's Charlie happy Thursday
there's new Star Wars footage so let's break
it down we see finn with his lightsaber we
get to see more Han Solo and we get to see
Han Solo in real life surprising the shit
out of people. There's been this new trend
the last couple of years where big Hollywood
movies try to do the reaction video thing
were the big stars surprise the crap out of
normal people Star Wars has just been using
Harrison Ford in their latest installment
but the big thing about this new clip is that
it's all about Finn. We learned that he is
a flame trooper or lease he starts out as
one it looks like he completely torches that
village killing a whole bunch of people Anakin
Skywalker style only instead of like Anakin
going to the dark side he has this complete
crisis of conscience so just to smell you
later to the Empire that's when he bails him
with Han Solo and then him with a lightsaber
look like a come much later in the film there
was some earlier clips where he had some dialogue
were he's like I have no idea what I'm supposed
to be doing like he's searching for a purpose
he just doesn't have an identity yet so you
get swept up in this big adventure and finds
himself this looks like it's on the starkiller
base which is a lot of people are guessing
is probably inside this ice planet will be
awesome if this trench opened up and revealed
the giant laser it would make it a lot more
defensible than the death Star any time I
think about death Star logic I just go back
to that family guy clip bitches Solaris can
we put a piece of plywood over that whole
or something and his love how old and worn
in all the heroes stuff is looking hot Han
Solo is like the biggest character and most
of these clips and it looks like he hasn't
bought himself a new pair close like 30 years
the blaster that he's holding looks a little
bit different from the one used in the original
trilogy but it does look reminiscent of that
is one of the most fun things about going
to watch the original trilogy is the everything
looks like so lives in worn in like yeah it's
the future they have amazing technology but
it looks so dirty like nobody has ever claimed
it is this really grand visual sense of history
that you don't get from say like Star Trek
films where it looks like the bridge of the
enterprise is an Apple Store alive you've
also been asking about the storm trooper here
this is what they're calling the right control
storm trooper and it looks like he has a stun
baton there I don't think that's a fibrillate
or anything like that the only reason I think
that it's able to block the lightsaber strike
is because it is charged with energy but the
rooster fighting it looks like Maz Kanata's
temple of the empire destroys that she might
end up eating it during this movie maybe she
gets away or Temple looks like it gets destroyed
the do use the word hope quite a bit in inner
that is like so many visual things like costumes
as well as lines of dialogue that they taken
from the original trilogy and given two different
characters in this new trilogy so because
they are getting so close and the movie coming
out what I recommend you do is you watch the
original trilogy coming you watch the prequel
to at least watch the original trilogy within
like a week of going to see episode seven
just so all that is fresh in your mind so
you probably recognize all whole bunch of
familiar stuff during episode seven they kinda
did that with the latest Bond film with Spectre
there just like a lot of the older Bond films
inside that film so exact same thing can happen
with Star Wars there's gonna be crazy Easter
eggs is gonna be so much fun that's really
the reason you watch a film like 10 times
that you watch the first time just for the
fun of it just because this is a spectacle
then you rewatch it for all the fun Easter
eggs but I think the can end up doing is it
just because you're so close the movie and
there there were calling this a fin teaser
though do this for the other new characters
so we make it like a ray teaser we might get
a Poe Damron teaser women seen a whole lot
him yet Oscar Isaac was telling funny stories
about Harrison Ford on the set he said he
said because Poe Dameron's characters a big
pilot Harrison Ford is big pilot in real life
is like do you have any advice for me you
note for any badass piloting tips and Harrison
Ford just deadpanned look at him is like no
not no not really know no one will ever be
more casual than Harrison Ford is an audible
wondering what's going to happen to Han Solo
this trilogy I do think at some point he will
end up dying in the Millennium falcon will
be his legacy like you'll pass it on to the
new characters just in terms of visual imagery
the morning falcon is always going to be an
identifier for Star Wars like if you don't
understand but the story is for Star Wars
you know the morning falcon like you recognize
it will characters die off new characters
come in you know in 20 years the price still
be a Millennium falcon flying around the galaxy
I don't even want to think about how many
Star Wars films are going to be in 20 years
is at least three spinoffs that we know about
and three main films so that six in the next
like 8 to 9 years what can happen next is
I have a whole bunch of footage for the flash
arrow crossover so to do a video for that
and I'm in a do a video for Jessica Jones
have a whole bunch of Jessica Jones footage
if you guys didn't know Jessica Jones is dropping
every single episode is dropping on Friday
so be sure to book some time for a marathon,
to try to at least like four or five videos
for the episodes I don't know if I'll be able
to do a video for each episode to just be
sure to subscribe to get everything and I'll
be posting updates on twitter and Facebook
throughout the weekend while youg guys wait
for everything to post you can click here
for all the other Star Wars trailers that
I've been posting and you can click here to
catch up on Jessica Jones before tomorrow
night thank you so much watching, let's high
five and I'll see you tonight!